it's Wednesday time for our pet of the
week segment and Amy clatterbuck with
hearts of Life Villages here good
morning great to see you thanks for
having us oh you've got an adorable
young man here can you tell us about him
oh this is our dear Irwin hi he's uh
he's a lab mix I think he's got a little
bit of husky and him don't leave that
alone six months he's a mix he is just
the sweetest and you say he's so smart
oh he's so smart he aims to please he
loves um he loves treats so that's what
he's looking for right now in this grass
was great in the car he's so good on
leash already at six months you expect a
little different but so he would be good
in a household with you said kids but
maybe older kids maybe older kids just
because he's a you know puppies are a
little mouthy and they don't understand
how rough they are but they like to chew
exactly
definitely how is he with other dogs
cats do you know he's great he's full of
energy so he's very playful okay I would
definitely suggest with a larger dog for
a meet and greet just because it can be
kind of in your face as a puppy he's
sure super playful so we'd want to make
sure the other dog was okay with that
don't want to irritate it exactly what's
his adoption fee Amy his adoption fee is
150 for puppies so he's neutered up to
date on vaccines and microchips and
ready to go he's got it ready
now you've got a special event coming up
tell us about it we are really excited
about this so for 10 years we've been on
the west side and Northwest okay
um we've moved into Henderson and we are
so grateful to be in their Community wow
this weekend we're um we're doing our
grand opening for the everyday adoption
center which is inside the PetSmart on
West Lake Mead Parkway okay and um from
11 to 3 we're gonna have vendors and
food trucks and a ribbon cutting and
we're doing some adoption specials too
so okay fifty dollars for adult dogs and
30 for adult cats
that's a really good deal all right so
if you're interested in adopting Irwin
he is a little mouthy maybe like your
teenagers in your house
you can email Hearts Alive Village I'm
just kidding the number and the email
are both there on your screen and if uh
if you do want to attend the event on
Saturday remember it's 11 to 3 at the
PetSmart on Lake Mead and Henderson
heart's alive again holding that grand
opening for their everyday adoption
center so if I have Raffles on-site
adoptions food trucks a lot of fun we'll
have all that information posted on our
website including this segment at
8newsnow.com Irwin was adorable